Worldview?
Well,
I,
I'm a great believer in him and liberty.
I think,
uh,
the,
the genius of the American experiment is
a respect for the dignity of the
individual.
And,
um,
that's why I'm opposed to a trade
restrictions.
Uh,
I'm opposed to most immigration
restrictions.
I think human beings are human beings
and,
uh,
and that they had deserve the dignity
of,
of freedom.
And that's a worldwide phenomenon.
I must say that in the 30 years the Cato
Institute is existed,
and I'm not saying we deserve credit for
it,
but,
uh,
the extension of human freedom has been
remarkable.
I mean,
hundreds of millions of people are freer
today,
more prosperous today,
uh,
because of the recognition that markets
work,
uh,
the expansion of trade,
the,
um,
uh,
recognition of the importance of private
property.
Um,
those are great things.
And I,
I,
I view them as universal.
I mean,
the Cato Institute is actively involved
in promoting these ideas in,
uh,
in the Middle East,
in Russia and Latin America,
uh,
China.
Um,
so we held the first conferences devoted
to freedom in the history of communist
China.
And in the history of the Soviet Union.
Uh,
we went to China in 1988 and,
uh,
we brought,
Milton Friedman there.
And Milton was treated like a rockstar.
Uh,
it was very exciting.
And then,
uh,
two years later we were in Moscow and,
and had the first conference they're
devoted to,
to political and economic freedom.
And,
uh,
so I'm very proud of the cato institutes
orientation.
It's not simply parochial.
I mean we are around the world trying to
promote the concept of the dignity of
the individual.
Well,
um,
you know,
the,
the basic kind of classical Roth Bharti
and approach to libertarianism is,
is,
uh,
that,
you can't have,
and this is a randy and I Iran's
approach to the initiation of force.
It's wrong that people should be able to
do whatever they want to do as long as
they're not harming other people in
doing so,
whether through fraud or physical
violence or a theft or,
uh,
whatever,
so that you want the maximum amount of
individual liberty.
But you know,
it's interesting.
Um,
it's not all clear cut in theory from a
purely rights standpoint.
What Michael Vick did with these dogs
was,
didn't,
uh,
offend anyone's personal rights.
But I think as a libertarian,
and maybe I'm,
I'm,
uh,
I'm getting in trouble with my
colleagues,
but I th I think that,
uh,
in a free society that you should be
able to say,
you know,
you can't torture animals and that's
going to be a crime and it doesn't fit
in neatly with a libertarian theory of
rights.
But I think it's,
that's the way it should be.
Of course,
I love dogs so,
well,
I think the proper role of the,
the government is the protection of
life,
liberty and the pursuit of happiness,
which is what the declaration of
Independence said.
I mean,
that's a very,
very,
uh,
radical concept that government should
be limited,
uh,
to protecting your right to live your
life as,
as you,
uh,
choose.
Um,
I also think,
you know,
the phrase,
the pursuit of happiness is uniquely
American.
I mean,
it is saying that life is a good thing
and that you should be able to enjoy it.
And happiness is not saying you should
go to a party every night.
It's saying you should be able to pursue
your values and your goals in life.
And,
uh,
I think that's a reasonable goal for
government.
Uh,
I,
you know,
obviously,
uh,
clean air and water,
you shouldn't be able to pollute what
the,
the average citizen has to deal with.
Uh,
those are legitimate functions of
government.